your uh kids and their mom are safe
though you said you moved them out of
the country
yeah like do you have any concerns for
your children they spent the summer in
Croatia at the beach is very annoying
because I was stuck here yeah
why are you leaving like why aren't you
with them and uh well two reasons
originally I wanted to see what would
happen Okay then in April I was arrested
by the sbu it's the State security
service of Ukraine yeah they picked you
up yeah everybody thought that uh you
were dead you were gone yeah a lot of
irresponsible people you know assured
everybody that I've been tortured and
murdered with no evidence whatsoever uh
you know a lot of people were like uh I
think I might have been one of those
speculators I was I was like I don't
know what's up with him but he's you
know he's cool no what happened was that
I was arrested he went silent because I
had you on Skype and we used to message
and then you just went ghost right like
you would not respond yeah I lost my
accounts on my uh Gmail because they
took my uh cell phone and then and they
took my accounts they took them over
um and so that's why I can't access the
coach red pill Channel or my previous
gonzalezura channel I had to start from
scratch and
um no what happened was that I was very
active on telegram I had about an 80 000
followers on Telegram and telegram is
very easy to translate into Ukrainian
and so a lot of people in Ukraine were
following what I was saying and
um yeah that was why I I came onto their
radar but you know they they came they
arrested me there were like eight guys
it was pretty cool you know eight guys
you know armed to the gills right uh
with like big rifles in the holes
shebang right and they came to arrest me
and they searched my entire apartment
and they videotaped it and they searched
every nook and cranny looking for I
don't know what you know Russian
propaganda some [__] like that I have no
idea and I was interrogated a few times
and it wasn't like in the movies it was
a very civil conversation I had
translator
and at the end of the day they cut me
loose because I was more trouble than I
was worth because I'm not a Russian
agent you know
um I didn't have any kind of Mission to
uh
you know any kind of you know any kind
of like secret mission or [__] like that
I'm just a middle-aged fart who happened
to live here and started reporting on it
um and uh what happened was that the um
the sbu cut me loose because there was a
lot of uh online stuff but what was
actually much more important was that
there were a lot of diplomatic efforts
because I'm a resident of three
different countries
or have been a resident of three
different countries so it started
becoming a political issue over somebody
who's just really inconsequential
because I'm nobody you know I'm just
here I'm watching it and I'm talking
about it but I'm nobody and I don't
really have any kind of real power or
influence over any of the events and so
they realized I was just much more
troubled than it was worth but uh until
my case is adjudicated
um I have to remain in karkov I I'm not
under house arrest but sort of like City
arrest if you will and if I try to leave
the country
um what will happen is of course they'll
run my name through the system and my
name will pop up and they'll arrest me
on the spot they told me this that I'll
be arrested and held uh you know in
prison and so I'm stuck here you know
and and as a practical matter leaving
cargo for another region of Ukraine is
just how will that change or improve my
position especially considering that
most of the nation
has uh intermittent electricity and the
internet because the Russians have been
hitting the electrical substations
because they're trying to interrupt the
uh the supply of weapons because the the
train system in Ukraine is electrical
and so they're not trying to harm the
civilians they're trying to interrupt
the trains the train system and so
they've been hitting them but here in
Kharkov they don't need to hit them
because if you look at the map uh karkov
is out of the way if you will of the
transportation of weapons from Poland to
the front lines and so that's why I you
know it I've lost electricity a few
times but uh it's been you know you can
count them in a couple of hands it's not
that big of a deal
um but uh no and so you know I'm sort of
like stuck here and if I were to move to
a different city in Ukraine wouldn't
improve my situation probably make it
worse especially it would be a city that
I didn't know and I don't know Russian
or Ukrainian and so that would play
against me and so it's better to just
sit tight and watch this warm fold
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out